[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera a tutti il mio nome daniele
angelozzi lavoro come scultore digitale
che cos'è uno scultore digitale beh come
il nome suggerisce uno scultore digitale
una persona che scolpisce cose stato i
modellini gioielli oggettistica varia
e lo fa utilizzando il computer
avvalendosi di programmi specifici tra
cui il più famoso forse uno che si
chiama anzi brush che quello che sto
facendo vedere in questo video mandato
alla velocità della luce la
caratteristica di questi programmi che
permettono di operare una modellazione
3d approcciandola un po mimando la
scultura tradizionale con l'argilla e
quindi con un approccio che poco tecnico
è un po più creativo organico direi
artistico ora lavorare con il computer o
una figata perché sarei bugiardo se
dicessi che non è più semplice rispetto
alla scultura tradizionale tanto per
fare un esempio se lavorassi con il
marmo ripartisse una scalpellata di
troppo e scavarsi troppo la materia
sarebbe un po difficile tornare indietro
con il computer contro z step back si
ricomincia come se nulla fosse successo
però questa sera vorrei anche sfatare
una credenza popolare molto diffusa il
fatto che una cosa sia operativamente
più semplice da fare non significano
automatico che sia più facile fare cose
belle perché comunque si tratta sempre
di una creazione creativa e quindi da
parte dell'operatore ci deve essere sia
una competenza tecnica saper utilizzare
il programma e sa per quali tasti
premere ma deve essere sempre coadiuvata
a quelle conoscenze estetiche
artistiche che permettono di infondere
il bello in quello che fa
e a tal proposito
quand'è che un'opera creativa può
definirsi bella utilizzo il termine
opera creativa perché opera artistica un
volti sonante e comunque a volte noi
facciamo anche prodotti che vanno
venduti
beh un'opera creativa quale che sia una
poesia una canzone un disegno una
scultura può definirsi bella quando in
qualche modo riusciamo a connetterci con
il fruitore finale con quest'opera e
scatenare delle emozioni velo di con una
maniera diversa che la maniera cosa
sempre quando vado in giro a fare
workshop e lezioni una scultura è degna
di tal nome di tal nome scusate quando è
in grado di raccontare o meglio evocare
nella mente di chi la vede una storia
una storia che per una scultura
ovviamente non è la storia della forma
del di quelle che iniziano con c'era una
volta e finiscono con il vissero felici
e contenti
una storia per una scultura se facciamo
un personaggio ad esempio è utilizzare
tutta una serie di artifici estetici e
creativi per far captare subito quello
che è il carattere del personaggio i
suoi atteggiamenti come si pone nei
confronti e le situazioni che ho messo
il bay ma perché uno degli esempi più
semplice da capire il be max è
costituito da tutte forme tonde ha
fondamentalmente una silhouette che più
larga alla base manca di punte ea una
scelta di colori tenui e questo
suggerisce un character che lento non
aggressivo pacioccone espira simpatia
ora
questa cosa non è prerogativa del
dell'arte digitale dell'era digitale
perché esiste sin dalla notte dei tempi
e qualsiasi opera classica capolavoro
dell'arte classica che possa definirsi
tale lo fa perché è in grado di
raccontare una storia non mi dilungo su
questo ma ci tenevo a mostrare almeno
un'opera ca d'oro che volino i suoi
figli di giambattista al po e quell
artista riesce davvero a scattare
un'istantanea a narrare un momento di
una storia che si avvia verso l'epilogo
tragico che spero tutti conosciamo
questo alla fine se mangia i figli
quindi un prodotto un'opera creativa
narra una storia questo è il punto
focale e fa specie pensare che oggi
nell'epoca social forse tutti con noi
che i socialisti teniamo diventare
prodotti e opere d'arte create da noi
stessi perché noi ci raccontiamo con le
storie e con i nostri post e ci
raccontiamo dando un taglio alla nostra
storia atto a veicolare particolari
emozioni in che le nostre storie le vedi
che sono i follower i contratti io
questa sera sono qui per raccontare la
mia di storia e mi scuso perché
all'inizio veramente volevo raccontarvi
ha pensato di raccontarvi di come fare
delle scelte sbagliate al momento giusto
ma ne a mente che preparavano la
presentazione mi sono reso conto che non
ero io e mi è venuto anche pensato a una
cosa che mi capita sovente ora non
vorrei sembrare immodesto ma io nel
campo e la scultura digitale sono
abbastanza conosciuto sia a livello
nazionale che internazionale
perché lavoro da tanto tempo perché sono
attivo nel campo della formazione e
cerco di partecipare attivamente anche
alle discussioni su gruppi e canali
online dedicati e una cosa che mi capita
a volte che vengo contattato una persone
che scoprono l'esistenza di questa
scultura digitale vedono il mio nome
online e mi dicono sai ho letto la tua
storia perché stasera non è la prima
volta che la racconto e questa mi ha
talmente tanto ispirato che ho deciso di
fare un po come te un salto nel buio per
inventarmi scultore digitale
ora questa cosa me potrebbero zingare ma
in realtà crea un sacco di disagio
essere destinazioni per qualcuno è una
grossa responsabilità e vedete una
storia può essere sì ispirazione dare
coraggio e motivare ma si è raccontata
male può essere ingannevole della realtà
e far prendere dei grossi granchi
quindi io questa sera ho deciso di fare
questo simpatico esperimento vi
racconterò la stessa storia due volte e
la prima volta utilizzerò dei toni
emozionali motivanti un po social like
narrata come se fosse un avventura e per
dare un titolo questa storia era brutto
che ama le storie a 1 e 2 per la prima
ho preso a prestito uno dei claim
secondo me più abusati e
decontestualizzati della storia che lo
stay hungry stay foolish pronunciato da
un genio visionario il nostro secolo e
come tutte le cose quando è diventato
tormentone ha perso un po il significato
originale e tanta gente che si è fatta
mare per la seconda storia invece
prenderò prestito una frase detta da un
personaggio a cui sono legato anche un
po effettivamente perché una volta l'ho
rifatto il 3d sta lì e il joker e in una
sua storia una volta dice sono pazzo non
stupido c'è una frase che ha dei
retroscena anche abbastanza profondi ma
non voglio perdere troppo tempo passa la
prima storia stay hungry stay foolish
questa storia inizia 15 anni fa quando
la scultura digitale sta diventando una
grande cosa nel campo della computer
grafica sta invadendo ogni suo settore
quindi dai videogiochi ai film ma anche
la produzione di cose tramite la stampa
3d di oggi ha 45 anni quindici anni fa
era un giovane adulto di 30 anni che già
aveva operato delle scelte volte a un
futuro professionale e queste scelte non
riguardavano la computer grafica perché
perché avevo preso una laurea con lode e
scienze biotecnologiche e mi apprestavo
a terminare mio ultimo anno di un
dottorato di ricerca sempre in
biotecnologie e fu lì che quasi per caso
mentre ricordo stavo cercando un sistema
carino per creare delle immagini carine
per per la mia tesi di dottorato che mi
imbattei in quest'oasi brace un software
che permetteva di modellare la materia
digitale come se fosse pongo e voglio
dire per uno come me che da piccolo col
pongo si era cresciuto questa cosa fu un
epifania prendendo a prestito un termine
del gergo giovanile
mind blowing quindi e novello blues
brothers cannes certo punto vede la luce
presi coscienza che avevo capito tutto e
qui ce la mettiamo una bella frase
motivazionale non volevo tanto curare il
mondo con la scienza quando farlo
divertire scolpendo draghi creature
mitologiche e anche donnine da questi
succinti quindi a questo punto comincia
l'avventura il viaggio iniziatico
novello samurai 2.0 dell'era digitale
che armato di penna anziché di katana
facendo affidamento su una enorme
motivazione una forza di volontà che era
quasi sovrumana un po come il lato
oscuro della forza e l'imperatore di
guerre stellari
comincio questo percorso di studi
totalmente autodidatta passando nottata
intera a studiare tutorial nel mentre
che di giorno facevo lavoretti per
mantenermi e di notte e studenti sono
lavori tempo per fare altre cose non ce
ne ha neanche per fare l'amore però
tutto si sacrifica in nome di un ideale
più alto
comunque passano settimane mesi anni e
finalmente dopo un po di tempo arriva il
primo successo la prima soddisfazione a
coronamento di tutti gli sforzi fatti
nella forma del conseguimento primo in
italia e oggi a tutt'oggi ancora unico
di istruttore certificato di brass che
significa la pixo logic della software
house che crea questo programma mi ha
fatto un esame detto tuttora ma lo sa
fare ecco la certificazione una
certificazione di per sé può essere cosa
piccola ma se vi dico che siamo solo 25
al mondo a potersi fregiare che questo
titolo la cosa si compia un po e sembra
dire che sono anche un po un discreto
vivo nel mio campo
adesso facciamo un salto veloce un fast
forward ianni e tralasciamo tutti gli
enormi successi che sono venuti dopo
fatto modelli che sono stati condivisi
dappertutto stato che sono andate sold
out sono stato anche invitato a los
angeles a un concorso di scultura
internazionale
e arriviamo qui questa sera ai giorni
nostri nel parco del teteks dove c'è
questo tipo che dice che sì è possibile
credere propri sogni fare un salto nel
buio e avere successo nella vita facendo
il lavoro dei vostri sogni fine della
storia me la prima e traiamo un po di
conclusioni adesso io non so voi ma se
anziché sul palco mi trovassi del
pubblico e sentirsi una persona che fa
un discorso in questo modo penserà
innanzitutto che se la sta tirando un
pochino e mi starebbe anche un po sulle
scatole però vedete io ci ha tenuto a
raccontarvi questa storia in questo modo
perché tanti di artifici retorici e
comunicativi che utilizzato al giorno
d'oggi sono abusati da tanti venditori
di fumo per fare leva su ansie paure e
speranze dei giovani e vendere loro in
cambio dei soldi sogni che poi si
infrangono quindi adesso vorrei
raccontarvi una storia nella versione
sono pazzo ma stupido deprivata un po di
tutti questi toni sensazionalistici
questa storia inizia sempre 15 anni fa
la scultura digitale sta diventando una
cosa grossa e io sono sempre al mio
ultimo anno di dottorato di ricerca però
gianni anni precedenti avevo preso
coscienza è una cosa importantissima
ovvero che a me lavorare nel campo delle
scienze non appassionava e l'avevo
capito anche guardando i miei colleghi
gente a cui si illuminavano gli occhi
quando leggevano un articolo scientifico
aspettavano un esito è un esperimento io
da parte mia ero lì sul bancone talvolta
maneggiava anche sostanza abbastanza
tossiche facevo una fatica enorme a
rimanere concentrato o a non pensare
tavoli me quindi vedrete a 30 anni lo
capisci che se ti avviso un percorso
professionale con questo main set poi
aspirare al massimo a raggiungere un
livello professionale parlo di livello
professionale non di tipo di professione
che è mediocre adesso mediocre un
termine negativo è una forte accezione
giudicante usiamo magari anche umile che
un po più soft però di base non c'è
nulla di mare a fare un lavoro che non
ci piace se quel perché vedete ognuno di
noi ha la sua propria concezione di
successo e realizzazione personale
quindi ci sta a fare un lavoro che
magari non è nelle tue corde se questo
crea i presupposti per realizzati nelle
cose in cui realizzarti ea me
personalmente non avrebbe creato nessun
problemi fare un lavoro che non mi
piaceva se ovviamente ci deve essere la
controparte questo mi assicurava di dava
delle sicurezze magari un contratto a
tempo lungo o delle condizioni
economiche per poter vivere in maniera
decorosa ma queste cose non c'erano
dall'altra parte c'era il campo è una
scultura digitale che non ci voleva un
genio per capire che sarebbe diventato
the next big thing nella computer
grafica inoltre devo aggiungere un
piccolo particolare perché se non sembra
semplicemente fare due conti e fare
della matematica io la scintilla
creativa ce l'ha sempre avuta sin da
piccolo che sin da piccolo ha desiderato
fare cose creative e questa cosa è
cresciuta negli anni e se non ho fatto
un percorso di studi in tal senso e per
motivi personali che questa sera non ho
né tempo né voglia di raccontare quindi
da lì ho capito semplicemente una cosa
non era tanto che non volevo curare il
mondo ma farlo divertire il discorso è
stato molto più semplice se devo fare la
fame tanto vale farlo provando a fare
qualcosa che mi fa brillare gli occhi
quindi da lì si ho iniziato un percorso
di studi è stato lungo e stato anche
difficile però vedete se io ho una
persona dico che dobbiamo fare 3 mila
chilometri mentalmente ci si prefigura
sempre che questo tragitto bisogna farlo
dall'oggi al domani ma in realtà gente
che fa il cammino e sentiamo di
compostela che bello lungo prendendo
facendo registrata percorrendo ogni
giorno giusto chilometraggio
quindi che cosa significa che qualsiasi
percorso di studio sia affrontato nella
maniera giusta che significa sicuramente
non cazzeggiare e metterci un po di
disciplina nelle cose forse si sa fare
le cose ma senza lancia di voler
imparare tutto e subito a parte il fatto
che diventa godibile e soprattutto non
richiede nessun tipo di sforzo sovrumano
è difficile ci vuole a metterci sì ma
non è solo umano è assolutamente nel
umani possibilità
e arriviamo infine a sta benedetta
qualifica di istruttore certificato e
zii brass è croce e delizia della mia
vita sì qui un po del mio ce l'ho messo
perché io il programma l'ho studiato lo
stimato bene e lo conosco bene però
l'ottenimento della qualifica di
strutture è stato anche un piccolo colpo
di fortuna anche abbastanza grossa in
realtà perché perché mi venne in mente
di cercare su internet se c'era la
possibilità di diventare istruttore
probabilmente uno dei giorni successivi
in cui questa questo programma di
certificazione fu creato quindi furono
le prime a scovarlo su internet furono
le prime a fare domanda e fui uno dei
primi ad essere esaminato e tanto per la
cronaca la prima volta sono stato pure
bocciato quindi ho dovuto ripetere
l'esame e che cosa è successo a una
volta presa questa qualifica
qualche mese dopo i tizi della pixo
logica non più deciso di chiudere
programma di certificazione morale la
favola 25 persone che erano state
certificate possono ancora dire essere
strutture certificate tutti gli altri
non potranno almeno per ora diventarlo
mai più quindi detta in questa cosa la
cosa si sgonfia perché fondamentalmente
si a parte il fatto che essere strutture
certifica che io so il programma e lo so
spiegare però per quanto detto agli
inizi conoscenza tecnica non è capacità
di fare cose belle per quello c'è tutto
un altro percorso di tipo artistico che
a tutt'oggi ancora continua perché sono
tutto fuorché bravo e inoltre manca
quella componente che mi può far dire o
può far credere che io sia più bravo
degli altri perché non lo sono
adesso scusate qui c'è un momento che è
potenzialmente molto lacrimogeno ci
siamo salvati dalla pioggia quindi
cerchiamo di evitare che l'acqua calda
qui sul palco quindi
per forzare i miei neuroni e muscoli
facciali a non commuoversi ve la dico in
maniera scherzosa
ho avuto un piccolo colpo di fortuna è
stato il conseguimento del settore
certificato eccetera eccetera
sicuramente la mia più grande fortuna
nella vita sono le persone che
attaccando la famiglia prima di tutti la
mamma è sempre la mamma questa stessa
urbe tata tutti i miei cambi rumore i
miei dubbi esistenziali quando da
giovane non sapevo che volevo fa due
fratelli che sono anche i miei migliori
amici facciamo un sacco di casino
cazzeggia ma ci divertiamo un sacco
adesso 1 st lavora montagna speriamo che
non se lo mangia un lupo e vere l'angelo
che con cui convivo da dieci anni che il
mia moglie che è la povera donna che si
sospetta tutte le mie presa male quando
nel corso del lavoro degli insuccessi
perché ci sono oppure quando fai
qualcosa per lavoro che ti chiami
diventa un'ossessione e quindi se una
cosa non ti riesce a crisi depressive
delle crisi di pianto dai pugni sulle
porte e fai saltare in aria le tastiere
che vuoi dire se ve lo dico con questa
faccia risulta poco credibile però è
vero credeteci
approfitto anche per farle gli auguri di
compleanno visto che oggi compie gli
anni
in ultimo sono qui questa sera quindi
nel palco del teteks per dirvi cosa
fondamentalmente nulla questa è una
storia vera le storie vere nun c'hanno
morale
io sì posso dire di fare il lavoro di
lavorare facendo la cosa che amo ma come
ho accennato prima quando una cosa
camera fi per lavoro finisce a volte
anche per odiarla io non mi sveglio
tutti i giorni pensando a che figata
devo scolpire volevo scolpire la cosa
che voglia scolpire quindi di base anche
questa falso mito della motivazione come
spirito che ti porta avanti un para dida
ridimensionarlo perché quando una volta
una cosa la fai per lavoro ti affidi
molto di più alla disciplina ea quella
forza che magari ti gratifica dopo e non
mentre fai una cosa io con questo avrei
concluso io spero di non avervi annoiato
ma a conti fatti anche la noia
un'emozione quindi in qualche modo la
mia storia il suo scopo l'ha raggiunto
tante grazie a tutti e buon
proseguimento
[Applauso]